I've done so many things in my life,
you know,
movies,
TV,
all this stuff.
Stand up.
But Joe for Okin,
Oh my God,
Jack and blast and cheeses here run Joe Rogan.
Yeah,
I get you got fans,
you know that.
Oh,
like all these different ages and all different kinds of people and uh,
I'm very proud of you.
Thank you.
One of the things that happened,
you don't remember this,
but you opened for me many times.
Louise Ck open for me.
Nick Depalo open for me.
So people that want a little show business advice open for me,
it helps them.
Then you get to go by me and uh,
you know,
I get to watch you guys become stars.
I've sold,
I'm playing fucking Chinese for us and Saugus some of the best standup comedy in
the world is at Chinese restaurants and Sargus.
And that's a fact.
Still to this day.
All those people that live there,
they don't know how good they have it.
Well,
you know what it is.
I,
you know,
you work with these guys,
you and I've worked with guys that are like genius,
you know,
a transcendent,
whatever word you want to use.
But
doing stand up is not about being funny.
It's about going into these shed holes and like developing this extra skin.
You know,
you,
you're a martial artist and sort of,
you have kind of that mentality.
But you know,
when I started it was like I came from,
you know,
I was an actor,
I was very serious person.
I was like an actor,
you know.
And I do like these obscure impressions,
Paul Scofield and Lawrence,
Lawrence,
Olivia,
you know,
all right,
it's on that and all this bullshit.
And I'd be playing at places like the sugar shack.
So you remember the sugar shack?
It was a black,
uh,
R and B joint and I opened for BB King.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I'm doing like John Lennon.
It was very important when we started them and the black,
the do some dirty shit,
man,
what the fuck are you doing?
Don't you know any jokes?
So in the back,
I get heckled,
my first heckler,
he said,
Yo,
suck.
And I said,
yeah,
fuck you.
Who are you?
He says,
I'm BB King.
I hired you a motherfucker.
Oh No.
And then I was doing,
I will never forget this.
Do you remember the channel?
The channel?
Yeah.
Channel the Rock,
rock and roll place.
So I'm opening for like these bands,
you know,
it was like that blues brothers scenes with the throwing shit at the cage.
Yeah.
So,
um,
the bouncer,
he says,
you know,
point to people and we'll throw them out.
So I point to them,
but then they bring them out in the alley and beat the shit out of,
you know,
but I,
I'm thinking because you're a martial artist.
So I,
it's,
I've kind of got this thing about people fighting and growing up in Charleston.
And,
um,
I think back on certain incidents when I was starting doing stand up and I was
at this place and calm AV and this guy stole one of my lines.
Now I know that you're bringing into that,
right?
So he goes offstage,
I hit with a right cross fucking cause over the tables and I'm thinking to
myself,
my friend says,
I thought you wanted to be Jonathan Winters and reds.
They don't do shit like that.
And then another time we were at the ground round in Brighton,
I'll never forget round round.
Yeah.
I'll never forget this Joe.
So amongst the guy on before me guy in the audience's throwing little lights,
things that I'm right.
So I said,
uh,
my opening line,
usually it's trying to get the audience to light cue,
you know,
or laugh,
make them laugh or whatever.
So my opening line was like the first mother fucker that throws something at me.
I'm going to knock 'em out.
You know,
you're not exactly setting the stage for hilarious comedy,
but uh,
you know,
I ran at work.
What's that?
Work out terrible.
I bombed.
You know,
people think,
you know,
when you do this for a while,
you've never bombed.
I mean,
there's no experience in life like bombing in Louisville,
Kentucky.
I'll never forget that.
And a guy comes up to me afterwards and he says,
and he was trying to make me feel good.
He says,
well,
I could tell by your tone,
your funny.
Ah,
you know,
but I'm doing shit like about subways and stuff.
They don't even know what they are.
Right.
So those early years there was like one,
um,
there wasn't even a comedy clubs.
So you just kind of did it.
I fell into it.
What year did you start?
Oh my God.
People,
you know,
people I am now at that point,
Joe,
what people come up to me and you know,
they say,
I'm so glad to see you.
I keep telling my husband,
I'm telling you he's not dead.
He is not tied.
So it's been like 30 or 40 years.
Um,
I don't remember the year,
but uh,
I remember those were the years you started?
No,
I don't remember.
I started in [inaudible] 88 and you were a legend.
The legend.
But you were for sure.
Dude,
I watched you one night at Nick's comedy.
Stop kill so hard.
I stopped.
I thought about quitting because I had only been doing comedy like a year and I
was like,
fuck this.
I can,
I gotta get the fuck.
Got It.
You know,
you know,
you know when I had that feeling,
Richard Pryor's first performance film.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Richard Pryor live.
He filled them in Long Beach.
I was,
I went to see that with Steven Wright and both of us walked out.
We said,
we don't even want to do this.
You know,
it was so intimidating.
Yeah,
I know that feeling,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
we got that feeling a lot in Boston and uh,
as,
as a kid starting out there,
it was,
I tell everybody that I,
I stumbled into the greatest comedy scene in the history of the known universe
in 1988 when I started.
It was insane.
Dawn Gavin was in his prime.
You were in your Prime Roger Person.
I would watch these guys go up.
Don.
Um,
um,
there was so many guys that were so fucking good.
Knox was killing back then.
There was so many guys that you would go any night you would go and watch some
of the standup comedy on the planet.
It was,
it was amazing.
Mike Donovan,
Mike Donovan.
To this day,
people don't know who Mike Donovan is.
He was a fucking Johnny most.
Do you know who Johnny most?
Most people don't know what's in my right side for the Celtics.
Yeah,
he would do this long.
What do you know what?
But it's funny you say in your prime because,
and I've talked to people who've been at it longer than me.
This is one job where you can get better.
Yes,
you can get better and more skillful,
you know,
but it's something that you,
you,
you just have to give the finger to the business because they're looking for the
fat guy,
the small guy,
that black guy that you know,
they're,
they're always looking for something other than what you are.
So you do what you do.
Like you've done what you did
business in terms of like movies and television shows.
Yeah.
They will try to lure you away and they lure you away with money.
But the business is standup comedies.
It's really about what you do in front of that microphone.
You know,
how the audience responds on
stage.
I followed a woman and uh,
she had a lot of TV credits,
but she had no material and it was unbelievable.
You know,
you forget when you do something,
you forget.
It's like you're a trained fighter,
your trend radio person,
you forget that in order to do it,
you've developed a certain set of skills.
Yeah.
And like in Boston they have a Saint Patrick's,
they breakfast where the politicians try to be funny and it's excruciating.
You know what I mean?
And you forget,
Oh yeah,
I do this all the time.
It'd be like me trying to give a speech before I came on this show,
I talked to Nick Depalo,
you know your buddy.
Sure.
And he says,
well,
Joe and I always talk about politics.
And I said,
well,
no,
nobody to help himself.
And nobody,
nobody talks to me about politics.
I'm just not that smart.
Good.
I'm done with politics.
I'm going to quit.
Yeah.
I want to talk about,
you know,
where we are in this country now is like,
um,
well I,
I kind of,
uh,
I don't like to not like someone because of what they believe.
So I just kind of do silly shit.
I was thinking the other day with the Democrats,
you know,
I'm gonna run,
I'm gonna run and that,
but they let the moderate lane,
the,
um,
Progressive Lane,
so I'm going to run in the breakdown lane,
you know,
just a silly little shit,
you know?
Uh,
I try to keep it upbeat,
whatever,
but I got into this,
I fell into this because I kept thinking I'm going to get an acting job and I
won't do standup.
This is going to fucking end at some point,
you know what I mean?
And I,
I have,
you know,
I like people,
kids would,
will actually ask me for advice and I say,
advice,
are you shitting me?
I fell into this shit I expected at the end.
But he,
I say,
all right,
do you want some advice?
Don't ever work at a place that's named after the guy.
Like if it's Vinnie's fucking pizza parlor,
a Joey Shithole,
blobbies moneymaking piece of shit.
When it's named after the guide,
it's never enough.
You know Nick's comedy.
Stop next.
Now I'm going to do something.
Feel okay.
Then we're going to play a little scene.
Okay.
Now you ask me,
say is Nixa mafia joint?
Is Nixon Mafia joint?
Yeah.
Is this next still around?
100% yeah.
Nick's is around.
Is it the same ownership and do you know that there isn't one inch of that
building that I didn't do cocaine?
I believe that it was.
It was really something.
I mean,
I mean it was like,
I know that,
you know,
I lived in La many years ago and it's like I'm driving around and say,
oh,
I know that's what,
so with next,
I know every spot in the building.